Let's go to CNN's Omar
Jimenez, who has been following
since just a few moments ago,
watching all this happened.
Did you hear anything new from p
We now know
there are six people who have be
including a police officer.
Do we hear anything
about their conditions
or anything like that?
Well, you know, we got the tragi
as we're seeing that
that five
people are dead,
six taken to the hospital
after this shooting.
And obviously,
when you first
get reports of
of an active shooter,
of an active aggressor,
these are the types of reports
that you worry about that
the situation updates
to the the casualties
that we're seeing here,
the fatalities
that are being reported here now
One thing that we did learn from
this as well
is that the the active aggressor
threat, as they described it, wa
They said the suspected shooter
has been neutralized
or the shooter has been neutrali
at this point.
We're also learning a little bit
more about
what was happening as this was u
but this is coming from a witnes
who is nearby,
who spoke to one of our affiliat
saying he got a call from his wi
who said there was an active sho
and that she was locked inside a
at the old National Bank here.
And so the man called 911,
but the officers were already aw
this was happening around
eight 30 in the morning.
There
He described it as a traumatic p
with his wife,
essentially calling him
from inside the bank vault
where she was sheltering at the
He's since talked to her
and that she's okay
but obviously this was a situati
that that the shooter was
was actively firing at folks.
And we know
at least one person, potentially
even others were sheltering
inside a bank vault
just to just to be safe,
just to protect themselves.
And so obviously, we've gotten t
from police that
that some of these casualties
have confirmed now into fataliti
and that others have been taken
to the hospital.
Their conditions are still unkno
We know the governor is headed
out to the scene right now.
We know there's law enforcement
at multiple jurisdictions that h
they are responding at the local
Louisville police, but also ATF,
And so I think at this point,
we're now
waiting to see what develops fro
including the potential identity
of the shooter here.
And we want to see if these numb
unfortunately, grow
as they as they typically do
when we get into
the early stages of reporting.
Mass shootings
like these are really terrifying
hearing that account
from inside of the bank,
a woman in a bank vault
saying someone was shooting.
There are lots of potential thin
that may have happened here.
We don't know at this point
if there was a robbery,
if this was a disgruntled
we don't know anything about why
but we do know now
five people
have perished in this shooting.
You've got one person
who's been taken to the hospital
Omar Hammonds,
thank you so much for following
this story for us.